today on this episode of bottom gear i'm
a bit lost right now ow
ow ow how am i always breaking
everything
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
hello and welcome to another very
special episode of trash taste
outside stays outside so
what are we doing today boys today we
will be going to hiroshima to do the
shimanomikaido cycling route which is 75
kilometers long
and we'll be doing challenges along the
way to see who is the victor so
basically the shimanomikaido
is this beautiful cycling road that
connects hiroshima prefecture to ehime
prefecture and it's this beautiful
island hopping experience
along the way there is a blue line on
the floor that goes from the start to
the finish along the whole road so you
know exactly where to go
anyone can rent a bike for less than 15
so it's super beginner friendly and
anyone can do this but
it is long and we will see who will die
who will make it
and who will be gone probably me let's
get to the video
cycling 75 kilometers in one day
i'm sure to some this may sound like a
walk in the park but
for the three of us there were
definitely some mixed feelings about it
hello
it is the day before specifically
um 30 minutes before the next day
when i leave technically speaking i
should have an advantage
over the other two boys considering that
i've gone
across like 150 kilometers on journey
across japan which is a
thing i did like two years ago and
because i didn't do it two years ago
and i haven't been cycling since then
i'm basically just gone back to square
one i'm a [ __ ] frail ass nerd okay
all i know is how to sit on my [ __ ]
couch and sit in front of my [ __ ]
computer
and watch animes and talk about anime
titties and now
i'm being asked to cycle like 100
[ __ ] kilometers in a day
are you kidding me it's gonna be hard i
just don't want it to be cold so i feel
like i'm definitely going to be on the
mid range like conor is definitely more
fit than i am
but i'm most likely more fit than god so
yeah basically i'm probably gonna have
the most boring
point of view the most average point of
view of this i've never like run a
marathon
i've never been involved in many like
physical activities that are this hard
i'm not trying to set expectations low
or anything but if i just
end up completing the course i'mma be
happy for myself i'm probably gonna win
i'm not just saying that for the meme
because i always said i'm gonna win but
i genuinely think this time
i'm going to win i've prepared i've
brought the right clothing
i am ready to get this fat w and i'm the
fittest out of the three of us
joey has only been to the gym like once
in like past two months this man doesn't
run he's gonna die
connor's probably hyping himself up
again and as he should not to jinx
anything with the antagonist card or
anything but
he needs a [ __ ] w man if he loses one
more time might as well change his job
title to professional l-taker so we
packed our bags and flew all the way to
hiroshima
and once again the night before we were
feeling fine
absolutely fine gentlemen we are doing
our second
i guess official special or like special
we planned out before how are you boys
feeling
just tired i'm trying i'm tired and i
haven't even done anything yet
technically
you know what i am [ __ ] exhausted
today yeah and
i have a whole [ __ ] eight hours of
cycling tomorrow
and i've gotta say what do you mean you
we all have eight hours of cycling
tomorrow
i gotta say i don't know how you boys
have been feeling about this
i am not looking forward to this i mean
we've known about this for like what
maybe a month or so
so i figured you know this is the end of
october now right and i was like all
right i have all of october to go to the
gym
train up and october just happened to be
the busiest month of this year
so i think i went once this year uh this
month yeah and then i was like all right
if i can't go to the gym
i can at least eat healthy i ate like
absolute garbage
so you're probably the one who quits
there so yeah i basically like debuffed
myself like crazy
i'm feeling okay about it i mean you are
the fittest out of the thing yeah
i guess physically technically you think
i love doing physical exercise
i hate physical exercise you know
[ __ ] drifting special
i'm in a chair all day i could die i
don't give a [ __ ]
that's easy work what is the longest
you've ever cycled i don't even know
i have i've never seen from my house to
the convenience i have never
cycled long distance i've never run long
distance i've never exerted myself for
like a long period of time i'm just
going to try and survive
and i mean look to be fair you've won
enough times on a special okay now
it's time for the winner to change so
didn't you guys all buy
clothes for this i told them guys i was
like
two days before i'm like guys amazon
only delivers tomorrow
this is your last day to buy things we
didn't get to try all the stuff
so we've all bought stuff do you guys
want to show off your clothes that you
have i haven't tried it on yet but
uh we'll see yeah i'll try mine i'll get
mine on all right let's try it all right
we're ready
it looks like a [ __ ] have you read the
one punch from manga
there's like a character that's the
garrow right sperm character
i it's got like padding as well here
let me see let me see that ass oh nice
this is like a cheap cosplay series oh
god yeah i know this is so comfortable
though
actually why don't all pants have this
built in yeah right oh my god all right
well nice what'd you think boys good
those are some really hard nipples you
got there man i always have stiffness
always no matter what those are going to
be we're going to get demonetised for
that
whenever you're ready joey whenever
you're ready
[Laughter]
you look like every eight-year-old
japanese man i see cycling
you look like you've got like a
diversity on look at this man's camel
toe
oh my god you like
we're gonna get something monetized
jesus christ get tea bag from this
you're really covered up dude can your
balls breathe they look like
it's a little tight and this is an l
size too can't stop staring now
now you just don't look at the dick
don't look at the dick
oh god i'm telling you the pink guy
knowing gone he probably [ __ ] up and
bought something
the completely wrong size that's a
hundred percent again
oh
wait do you not have like padding like
underneath no no
oh well boys i did get a little gift
because i knew that you boys would [ __ ]
up i bought
pants with padding in them because i
just had a feeling that you both would
just not realize you should probably i
mean i'm
not as monkey brained as this film
because did chris buy yours no i bought
minecraft yeah what are you what are you
talking about
so there you go i'm a nice friend i
bought gifts just in case they forgot
so there's pants for you ex-algon do
they go on oh my god
it's almost like they fit look at that
what a good friend
i can't feel these at all like cannot be
always
you look like you're wearing a tiger oh
my god
are you ready for tomorrow i am not
ready for tomorrow
i feel like i have the perfect setup
here i'm dreading this more than i
already was
and i feel like a [ __ ] idiot now i
feel like conor now this this is what
you do on your channel connor
i just talk about anime titties i'm a
disembodied voice what what the [ __ ] am
i doing the only thing that's dreaded
more for tomorrow than you is you're
nuts like
in a [ __ ] vice grip right you should
text sydney and let her know you're not
gonna be off kids anymore
like that's off the table this is live
footage of god's future children dying
i'm just
finna leave now man this has been the
sperm men i guess
we're gonna be cycling tomorrow so we're
gonna go to the onsen now because this
is a ryokan so we're gonna go relax
before tomorrow
before we start the horrible horrible
task all right bye
[Music]
it is 805 in the morning ladies and
gentlemen it's a beautiful morning in
onomichi hiroshima today
wow and we are uh i sound like a weather
reporter
it's a beautiful day it's a beautiful
day here we wanted to start at seven
it is now eight or five eight or five a
little late
hoping that won't come to bite us in the
air i just realized i was like looking
at an imaginary watch it's like yes
it is also 805 i can concur with you
guys so
right behind us oh okay it's leaving but
that is the ferry that we're getting on
that's just live
so we're getting the next ferry over to
the first island to start the race and
where we're going to begin the
the group cycling which is the first
part and then we have challenges on the
subsequent islands that we don't know
yet so
we're gonna be figuring that out
ourselves so the first island is just
gonna be us filling
things out so we're just gonna be
enjoying the beautiful views chilling
with each other no competition just a
nice time just the boys hanging out
boys on tour voices on tour we have
bikes if you want to
have a look we have kitted these out
it's like pimp my ride right we got the
battery charging the gopro we got
helmets with gopros we got
this thing which carries our phone this
is kitted out this is 2020.
this is a fire hazard technology we've
got walkie-talkies so
whenever we're not in view we can still
talk with each other sorry i'm
i just realized you're listening to this
now nabi uh roger that watch that
yeah i heard that guy
totally legal in japan by the way just
saying all right i guess we're ready to
go all right all right let's get going
let's go
here's how the route works the shimanami
kaido is made up of
seven islands connected via bridges with
an easy route shown in solid blue
a hard route shown in the dotted line
and a partial fairy route
shown in red most locals recommend that
newbies split the route into two or
three days
but we were gonna do it in one day all
right so we're at the first
one this is so much fun we're living we
keep talking two meters from each other
we just got off the ferry
it's just over there and this is the
first leg of the race where we're gonna
be together
so we're just gonna have like a
leisurely stroll for the first part
we're gonna test the waters right
we're gonna see what's ahead of us
what a good start what a good start so
we just follow the blue line on the road
that's all we have to do the whole
blue line right there race you can see
it on the floor the epic blue line
the epic blue line that is going to be
our guardian our savior today
our shepherd all right all right well
let's just go good luck go right into it
8 40. let's go let's go boys
oh [ __ ] i didn't see the blue arrows
over there yeah look out for the blue
arrows
this is already like so confusing is it
recording
this was it the start of our challenge
the first island would just be a
leisurely ride
no challenge no pressure there was
little we could do
to [ __ ] up
i think we just ran a red light breaking
traffic laws already and it's on camera
[ __ ]
you good yeah my gopro keeps moving
joey's already [ __ ] something up
come on joey seriously seriously let's
go
[ __ ] you guys i'm out let's go all right
we are on right now on our way to
inoshima which is the
second island it's really scary though
because we're right next to a bunch of
these like tractors and whatnot
oh god let me just slide on through
thank you sir
see now i'm not used to cycling at all
and these cycle paths are pretty narrow
we're right next to
where any cars could just hit us luckily
this isn't southeast asia where's the
free-for-all
is it bad that my legs already hurt i'm
right there with you joey
i am not looking forward to today it's
nice though i love being on a bicycle
feels good my dick is itchy i don't know
what that's about
let's probably fix that this is meant to
be the leisurely part i don't know
what's coming up next
so far the blue line is just uh on the
road straight ahead as you can see
my pants are falling off whoa nice ass
there joey
looking dummy thick from my angle look
away
don't point the copper on my pants it's
such a beautiful country side of japan
it's just so nice it's so relaxing we
shouldn't forget that this was a
marathon
not a race we had all day and
well the early signs weren't great hey
how you doing luke i'm doing well how's
the driving going
it's nice it's very uh my legs are
pretty sore
did you hear that jerry said he's
already tired yeah how are you doing
it's a little chilly my nips are a
little
a little perky but i think we'll be fine
that was like no cars on this road god
i'm regretting this already is it bad
that
my legs already like are burning a bit
and
my ass hurts so much already the padding
does nothing i swear to god
my legs are getting a slight bit tired
already which is a little worrying
yeah same here is anyone's arse [ __ ]
rock hard
right now
oh what's up oh look at that dog look at
the dog look at the dog
ah come here let me chase the dog i want
a good shot of the dog
no luckily we had already been cycling
for a while
have we been cycling for 20 minutes 10
minutes [ __ ] my life
watch out for the car i know i know is
it my ass that sort of card or is it
the seat that rocks that's rock hard
probably just not gonna be able to walk
after this day am i
how you doing not optimal i do kind of
prefer the drifting video so far
this is like that meme of uh when god
realized he was in a club and then the
sudden realization of [ __ ]
i could be watching anime right now
dan that water looks lovely
i hope there's an elevator but i have a
feeling there isn't going to be an
elevator
with us already struggling some locals
were kind enough to show us how it was
done
oh my god this guy's showing us how he's
styling on us
stop flexing god i wish i was him
wait are you sure this is the right way
i think so yeah the blue line's here oh
is it okay
we follow the damn blue line near the
end of the first island we would
encounter our first of many challenges
an uphill climb oh cool a three percent
incline
for a kilometer amazing oh god
kill me now please i gotta rest my legs
[ __ ] that
god i wish that was me right now i just
wanted to take a jaunty stroll just to
show the audience the beautiful scenery
over meanwhile i'm staring at gaunt's
crack
that's the best view arguably over you
get to see the best hills over
why didn't we choose the electric bikes
i don't know
we should have if humans wanted to do
this they would have just never invented
cars
they would have never [ __ ] tamed the
horse we would have to climb a hill
every time we'd cross an island we were
tired
and we hadn't even finished the first
bridge yet
ah flat road
oh it's flat ah
speed it up a little bit at least i got
here before joey where are you guys can
you hear me over yeah i'm at the
beginning of the bridge
over i'm just going on to the bridges
while over i can see you
over oh oh you're not too far behind me
nice
holy [ __ ] i've never been jealous of an
old woman in my life
without all the one on the moped it is
a lot more beautiful than how i feel
right now i'll tell you that
bridge is so long and vast i love how
you can
actually see the traffic as well as it's
driving past you can see the shadows
that's very neat as an idea it sounds
great
oh yeah let's just cycle 70 to 100
kilometers
document our efforts make a youtube
video about it
what a brilliant idea what a brilliant
[ __ ] idea
it is free for bicycles lovely
it's 50 yen but it doesn't know there's
any way to prove that i did it
thankfully what goes up must come down
oh
[ __ ] lovely we've got a downhill for
about a kilometer
oh i love it hell yeah
[Applause]
deja vu i've just been in this place
before
isn't life great connor i love this oh
drift king drift king i'm using my drift
skills right here
that i learned in the last special oh
drift king
hit the brakes however maybe i was
feeling a bit
too good oh my god it's beautiful
look at the view oh [ __ ]
did you get that on camera oh there they
are let's get it going gamers
oh my god that nice breeze holy [ __ ]
man you really feel the [ __ ] wind
resistance now
is that my tire what is that noise
i think i've got a flat tire oh no we've
got an injury you got a flat tire
yeah it's making a [ __ ] horrible
sound all right i'm right behind you
on brand i had broken something else on
a special and of course
the boys were very very understanding
[Applause]
has broken another thing on another
special
how am i always breaking everything oh
that's [ __ ] that tire is [ __ ]
oh no that's actually fun when did you
realize was this on the hill
when we were going down i think i might
have pop sign because as i was going
down all i heard was
boom boom boom boom boom really yeah
that's bad i can't even like cycle
yeah yeah at all kind of the most
expensive thing on the set as joey
called him
how do you constantly break [ __ ] in
these specials how do you constantly do
that
if we get you another bike are you just
gonna break it again sir
how you boys feeling um not too bad i
think it's just painful when you're
doing it right now i'm not that tired
the padding is a lie padding is a lie
yeah i don't know mine's kind of helping
it still hurts
every time i take my ass off the seat i
can feel the blood circulating again
into my ass i feel like my ass has taken
10 dicks right now
uh my tyre has popped completely
okay and i guess we didn't plan for this
are you off the bridge yeah we're off
the bridge on the road so i'm thinking
yeah pick me up how did this break i why
is the road called rocks on it
i have no idea why stop having rocks all
right see you connor
bye boys have a have fun but how much
battery is left from the
jesus [ __ ] sake your batteries just fell
out too
everything fell out this boy i can't get
a w today man
see you at the finish line baby i'm so
[ __ ] sad that my thing
[ __ ] itself and uh that was another
day
in the life of sea dog collateral damage
va
sea dog likes to break our [ __ ] va why
oh who why did my [ __ ] [ __ ] die
i can't believe he broke another thing
what's he gonna break next
why is it the one dude who's always the
most optimistic about the challenge
ends up [ __ ] himself over somehow
he broke two cars in the drifting video
and now he's just broken a bicycle
not even one hour into the cycle this
man is single-handedly
eating our budget alive and you know
what the worst part is
conor had to break down during the best
part of the [ __ ] route
aka the downhill part because of course
he did while the boys went off without
me
i needed to figure out a way to fix my
bike
and i don't really know how to do that
you want to see how [ __ ] this tire is
look at that oh my god look how bad that
is
i actually really wanted to do that and
we're on the nice bit as well we're on
the home stretch
tell you what cycling up that hill was
[ __ ] pain
all right let's get let's get in boys
let's go you can mash up
very slowly boys can you hear me however
oh we see you we see we're coming
towards you now all right there they are
in front of us
[Music]
ladies join my only fans that wasn't
very far at all was it
wait so where was this recording oh [ __ ]
so right now we're here on the map right
and the bike fixing place is down here
oh so
you're going on a journey so i need to
drive down there get my bike fixed and
then we'll come back probably up up here
and then based off we're going to do
draws now right
so we have alternative routes there's
the ferry boat
the hard route and the easy road the
normal standard yeah
what we were going to do is one of us
was going to take the boat
one of us was going to take the hard
route and one of us was going to take
the easy route
now because we have a clown within the
group
who has [ __ ] up the entire schedule
connor is going to be taking the boat
because he has to uh
basically get his [ __ ] fixed get us get
his [ __ ] together
so what we're going to do is we're going
to have a race to see
who can get to the next checkpoint first
and this will determine the points for
the next challenge
yeah and how difficult that will be it's
basically just gonna be between me and
joey drawing the easy and hard route
isn't it well the thing is right so the
ferry boat goes all the way here to
here right yeah yeah so whoever's going
on the easy route
is going to eventually go on the same
route so let's find out which one of
these boys is doing the uh easy and hard
i'm going to mix it give me the easy
please
i want the easy i'm so jealous of connor
cause i wanted the boat
because the boat i don't want to go on
the boat but it makes sense that i have
to go on the boat for the schedule this
is the boat
that i'm gonna be taking he's getting
the easiest easiest route by default
because he's a [ __ ] clown clown dog
va
i have a piece of paper in each hand let
me mix them up again just to make it
real fair
gotcha gods please who wants to get your
pull who wants to do it
i'll [ __ ] do it all right which one
do you want i want the right one
gotcha gods please give me the easy
route come on gamers
come on no no
yes joey's got the hardwood
i almost couldn't jump there because i
was my legs are already jelly
but we know who the real loser is that
boy i want a cycle man i want to go
i was saying like along the route i i
love how connor is always the most
enthusiastic about these
trash taste specials and yet he's always
the one who [ __ ]
[ __ ] stuff over [ __ ]
can this man take any more there elves
find out on the next episode of trash
taste we should clean that which is
happening right
it's happening right now now this is a
straight-up race
no no more leisurely cycle in the park
we've got to go full force now first
part was a little warm up with the boys
little nice session now we've actually
got to
separate ourselves and go at it alone or
a nice car if you're me
i'm jealous man i wish i popped it i'm
kind of happy but i also kind of wanted
a cycle man because the comments are
going to call me a [ __ ] [ __ ]
no you're not a [ __ ] you're just a
clown i'm just a clown
the next part would be a race across two
islands
gantt had the easy route i had the hard
route and connor would have to get his
bike fixed take the ferry across one
island
and cycle the rest to the checkpoint on
the fourth island the routes would
determine the placings for the next
challenge and only the two winners would
be allowed to enjoy the refreshing
ekiben ice cream waiting for us at the
halfway point
all right give us a countdown and we'll
start this race all right three
two one go best of luck boys let's go
see you in a bit clown all right
let's [ __ ] go
while my route was advertised as the
easy route i
quickly realized that might have been
false advertising
oh no and we're starting off with a
[ __ ] hill of course we are
did we get this mixed up was this the
hard route
i think this might have been the hard
route this is such a quiet town god damn
guys are we sure we got the right thing
with the easy and hard route
why do you say that over this is not an
easy route
i don't know man i'm having a jaunty
stroll over here over
it's been nothing but hills for me oh my
[ __ ] god
the gotcha gods are on my side baby gone
is it is there any hills for you
he sounds like he's [ __ ] dying uk god
help out of the hills are they are they
really steep
i immediately hear a super steep hill
i'm going downhill now thank god
i'm glad you're having a good time right
hopefully the rest of it's easy for you
oh it looks like i locked out boys
it's a little stuffy in this car you
know i really wish i had the breeze and
the
hills blowing on me over you may win
this race connor but you still took the
biggest l
over you having a nice drive connor
god i'm telling you man it honestly it's
a little too comfortable i really wish i
was breaking a sweat here well i'm glad
you're having a good time [ __ ]
[ __ ] you get out of my face get out of
my face
i don't want to see your face anymore
man
it's a beautiful day god it's a
beautiful day while the boys were busy
cycling their routes
i was having a nice relaxing time while
my bike was getting fixed by the way if
we stopped for sandwiches at some point
lawsons have a tuna and egg sandwich it
is my favorite it is the best sandwich
at lawson's
there's no better combination of egg and
tuna so we're gonna get it changed over
there
and we've got about i'd argue about 10
minutes to get this done
so we need to be pretty fast
that's so sweet of them i don't know why
that warms my heart normally either
people like
scurry away when they see a camera but
they were pretty pleasant about it
i needed that that's my power for the
day
what's that is that fish in a can that's
actually fishing again
hi so here's my lunch today i have the
ham sandwich
from uh family mart honestly i think the
family mile sandwich is a mid but that's
fine
i went for a carry sweat and i have a
melon pan as well for extra sugar
we however were having a less than
pleasant time
paul hills oh god damn it
he's dying i'm having a great lunch
i'm having a ham sandwich with a melon
pan
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you unfortunately
my nice lunch may have come back to bite
me so we just arrived at the dock
you just checked the time and we're
looking at the schedule so it says
inoshima which is where we are now
there's two different boats there's one
that comes at 11 which goes to a
different place which is sunoy and sawa
and italy yeah it says
it says here uh 1125. see down there
right
which one sour 1125
1125 yeah i think that's
we're not on sauer we're in
uh yeah you know shima
this is the one going backwards and this
is the one going forward and the one
going forward we just missed by
20 minutes [ __ ] so that would mean if we
the next one would be at 1pm
there's no way we can do that so i had
to improvise
but the important thing is the boys
wouldn't know i'll turn my location
sharing off so they can't see where i am
so the boys don't know this and we don't
need to tell them he's gonna drop me off
at the port
i'm gonna cycle like i went on the boat
now you're gonna think that i went on
the boat
when this video goes live they see the
first draft they'll be like what the
[ __ ] connor you drove
yes i drove because we missed the damn
boat about 20 minutes we could have made
that as well if we knew
because we spent like 20 minutes [ __ ]
around in family mart [ __ ]
i'm so dumb all right let's drive [ __ ]
i've skipped so much now while conor was
off on his bizarre
adventure i had pulled way further ahead
than god
so far in fact that i was just enjoying
my ride
surprisingly not sweating maybe because
it's cold
or it's chilly it's a chilly morning
here in hiroshima
mind you it's 11 am on a thursday
people should be out and about doing
stuff
what the [ __ ] is that
what the [ __ ] is that did you see that
i wonder if conor got the fairy on time
be interesting to see i did make it at
least as far as the boys would know
so we're gonna we're pulling over real
quickly now to get this
bike out of the boot i'm trying to be
quick because i want to catch up because
i don't want them waiting for like 10
hours
so what's our story uh your stories you
drop me off of the boat
and i'm on my way and my location
services are disabled
uh because they broke you at the 11 30
i got the 11 30 and i'm coming down
at my i'm blasting it down i said i was
gonna go ham
that i'm holding back so they'll be like
wow he got here fast didn't he i'll be
like yeah
of course i just wanted to capture my
boys didn't i come on come off i didn't
drive nah get off it
[ __ ] me dude i'm not looking forward to
this
see you gamers i'm going very fast
i am the speed right now i do not
currently see the bridge
which is a little worrying i just hope
the boys don't figure out how [ __ ]
cheated
my bike is making a funny noise
which i won't lie it's a little bit
concerning
the shimanami kaido is one of the most
scenic cycle routes you can find
in all of japan and in between our
suffering and conor's
improvisation we just had to find time
to
appreciate the view
[Music]
you see this god damn look at this water
[ __ ] it's so beautiful why is it so
beautiful i love it
i'm [ __ ] dying right now but man
can't complain about the view that is a
beautiful beach
i'm losing my [ __ ] over a beach i hate i
don't even like beaches
oh my god look at that view
[Music]
oh what is this place i'm just
just cycling past the temple here look
at that
ah the beautiful view the nice sea
breeze
this was meant to be a challenge but i
was having a great time
so long yukuma you're a beautiful
coastal town
and a beautiful coastal island port
island but it is farewell to you island
number three
and we are on to island number four
omisima where the first checkpoint is
going to be
let's go the roaring dragon of tatara
bridge
let's try to clap your hands here then
strange things will happen
holy [ __ ]
that's so cool i promise that after this
i will be going to the gym regularly
you know what's a weird flex i could
honestly walk
the rest of this way to the checkpoint
and i probably still get there first
maybe i am fitter than i thought i was
having accidentally been given the hard
route though
i wasn't having a great time
come on gang imabari 40 kilometers
let's go no problem i'm gonna name off
all the things i like anime titties
sydney my fiance
orange juice anime
manga ice cream god i love ice cream
you know would be great right now
mcflurry the hill leading up to the
third bridge would almost break me
and it would get even worse when i found
out where joey was
anyone there i can eat you over
i'm broken man i'm i'm i'm a broken man
right now
well you probably wouldn't like to hear
then that i've just arrived at the
checkpoint
[ __ ] you
i'll be i'll be waiting at the
checkpoint for you boy
oh [ __ ] him [ __ ] joey
you know what [ __ ] lifting off things i
like how about listing off things i hate
joey for being an australian [ __ ]
who's [ __ ] ahead of me right now
probably enjoying a nice
[ __ ] lunch
i've got a second winds now huh let's
keep going
other things i hate connor for being so
[ __ ] smug
[Music]
i'm thinking that this would be
something that we don't want to do
you know what happened today someone
destroyed
the [ __ ] toilet in the onsen
so i couldn't even enjoy a nice [ __ ] in
the morning
no i'm complaining that i can't even
[ __ ] correctly [ __ ] nature
[ __ ] beauty [ __ ] this ocean
[ __ ] these mountains [ __ ] newton
and your [ __ ] conservation
laws of the conservation of energy or
whatever that
[ __ ] thing is why can't energy just
be created
why can i just not create the energy out
of thin air right now
to put me across the [ __ ] bridge
god wasn't the only one having a hard
time though well [ __ ] i've gone the
wrong
[ __ ] way i guess that serves me right
for cheating right that's
my punishment for being a [ __ ] dirty
little cheater i've gone so
far out unnecessarily you know what we
realized on the road it says
the place where we started that i was
cycling towards
and i'm cycling away so i probably just
cycled an extra 34 kilometers
the wrong [ __ ] way like a [ __ ]
monkey
could be at home chilling watching some
anime
playing some video games but no we had
to go on a [ __ ] boys trip
and go cycling because i've cause i've
done that in my life so far
i love exercise gone viewers like
watching you suffer right
what a great [ __ ] idea chess i can do
that easy
easy win against connor no [ __ ]
problem drifting what's the worst that
can happen in drifting
[ __ ] roll over crash and die who the
[ __ ] gives a [ __ ]
that'll make great content well there's
the bridge again from a nicer angle
and like every [ __ ] vlogger is
looking at this right now being like
oh look at this amazing view oh my god
view
[ __ ] this view [ __ ] these islands
[ __ ] the water just give me some [ __ ]
anime titties man
well i'm looking at the map right now
gant is on the bridge
he's halfway so he should be coming
around soon
i'm enjoying a very nice ice cream right
now it's apparently a a type of
mandarin that is only really grown in
akima is known for its mandarins
so this mandarin ice cream i'm having
[ __ ] nice but somehow my little
tantrum would get me through
i apologize for that had a bit of a
breakdown there
that wasn't very monkey of me here he
comes
god's mandated everybody round of
applause
made it all that was left now was to
wait for the last boy
all right it's 1.2 kilometers average
three percent let's do it boys
if these boys struggled i'm sure as hell
not going to
i won't allow it i'm too prideful
well looks like we've gotten a message
from uh from connor
looks like um he's about to join us and
he's about to hit
that hill that hill that i don't know
what you mean i mean it was just a
regular hill to us wasn't it
it's a nice perspective for me man
that's a money shot eh
what a beautiful [ __ ] view god i want
to swim and it's so bad
i can't wait to have a [ __ ] beer and
some ramen man
ah i see the drone
i see the drone i've never seen a person
take so many yells in one day man
i wish i was in front so i could
stop at all these beautiful landmarks
for you and just
take it all in but unfortunately the
boys are waiting for me
so while i'm waiting for connor i
finally got my ice cream guys
this has all made it worth it all this
suffering for this one ice cream
it's a pretty damn good ice cream cheers
it's been roughly two hours since i saw
him last
oh there he is there he is there he is
there's a boy
yes we've done it we've made it the
first part
i would like to now do my victory speech
i'd like to thank my legs and my ass for
not giving up
i would like to thank pokhari sweat for
making a great energy drink
i am tumbling towards the end so i will
hold on to the bars and break now but at
long last
we would finally be reunited oh is that
a brand spanking new bike i see
they said you couldn't change ties you
had to get a new bike that's not fair
you just upgraded your bike basically
don't you think it looks the same
no it looks way better yeah it's like
some sleek and black what do you mean
like that has anything to do with it
boys are back together
[Music]
we were about halfway through and we had
a bit of time to reflect yeah the boys
don't know i've kind of cheated so far i
mean
it's not really cheating because i would
have had to i'm trying to justify to
myself so i'm doing
but hi joe you're listening good good
can't hear me
fantastic but i think we have a few more
challenges up next and we don't really
know what they are pretty confident that
i can get a dub
in the next few challenges i took a
pretty big hour being the last to arrive
here
which sucks but next one look at the
next one i'm feeling strong i feel good
i'm ready
all the other boys look dead i'm pretty
sure i'm gonna be fine
what up squad it's the king it's been
good it's been having fun
um i've just been enjoying the scenery
more than anything like yeah of course
it's [ __ ] tiring because we've been
what
doing it for the past three and a half
hours now we've cycled about 35
36 kilometers i think we're about
halfway yeah just oh my god every time i
go onto
that bridge like this one as well but
the other two
included it's just man the view from
there just never gets old it's so
[ __ ] nice and there's all these like
little like
weird quirky things along the way that i
just happened to catch and i'm like what
the hell is that so
yeah it's been good second half it's
gonna struggle a bit
but uh yeah i'ma murder them
i wanna die the fourth island was simple
it would be a drag race across a
straight road playing a game of cat and
mouse
we would start from the person who went
on the hardest route got
to the least hardest route connor in one
minute intervals
if anyone was able to overtake someone
they would have to do
20 squats on our already dead thighs
so whatever you do don't look
back all right kant goes first minute
and a half
three two one
go all right that's gone oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] me man oh this burns so much
already
do you reckon you can catch him it's
gonna be hard i mean it's a minute and a
half right i don't care if joey passes
me i just really hope conor doesn't pass
me
three two one go
you got this joey catch up to that scum
all right now it's just me oh my ass
hurts you know what i don't want to see
connor's smug face as he passes me
four three two
one and go wish me luck i gotta get it
we're gonna get low for aerodynamics can
we all
just agree just to get along
we're friends right i'm already getting
tired what the [ __ ]
i think i can see you gone joey can see
me
oh god ah i'm [ __ ] dying
you're almost there oh my god is he in
the finish line
oh god i can see jerry he's so close
no matter what mother nature wants he
can't stop me oh my god i [ __ ] see
him he's right there
come on catch up oh god
no i could see them both
hey gaunty poo oh
oh oh
damn it i was so close oh wow we're all
really close oh god
i would have killed you if i had any
more time i think you can tell
the shield difference in tiredness right
now i was like [ __ ] making hentai
moans
and like all like the japanese people
like that was like they were just
looking at me being like
what the [ __ ] is going on with that guy
so we're gonna take about a
three hour break i'm i'm just gonna take
a break for the rest of my life
and just never do this again i'm so sad
i did such i had three minutes like
basically caught up to gone
with a three-minute head start yeah mind
you though you've cycled what like a
quarter of what we say hey man you'd an
hour break i don't want to hear it man
you've had
a plenty of break joey
[Music]
all right now that we did the cat and
mouse race which i [ __ ] lost which
was the worst idea we could have had
[ __ ] love almost died i just i just
want to get through this day now
the producers have our final challenge
for us today for the final stretch
of the competition we need to figure out
what it is
time trial that's just a race with extra
steps
it's a race with attitude oh my god if
that was a 100 meter dash
this is like a marathon try our best to
enjoy ourselves for these remaining two
let's just have fun guys because i am
having fun
right now can you see how much fun
i'm [ __ ] having if it's for [ __ ] i'm
having a great time even though i'm
losing let's just
jump right into it let's jump right in
jump right into the jump right into it
man let's jump
off a cliff for the whole journey so far
we've been able to live
track each other but we've all turned it
off now so none of us will know
where we are the only way we can figure
it out is if uh someone wants to reply
to the radio so i'll just be like
gaunt shucks penis there's a radio over
there
um and if he wants to reply he can or if
i'm right behind gone i can just pretend
that i am i'd be like over the final and
longest island we would be doing a time
trial we would be going at five minute
intervals meeting up at the viewpoint
before the final bridge
the winner would have the fastest time
and the losers would have to do
one squad for every minute they arrived
after that we needed to make the last
checkpoint before
4pm to see the final bridge before
sunset
failure was not an option okay starting
now
[Music]
oh god i'm already not good ugh
so yes the question is when will conor
and joey pass me
and will it be will i be
uh how can i phrase this
five four three two
one go all right see ya
good luck this was it the final stretch
running almost on empty i would
immediately [ __ ] up
wait did i go the wrong way
[ __ ] i went the wrong way immediately
oh my god
let's go of course
the boys would let me take this [ __ ] up
gracefully i don't know how god missed
the turn it was pretty [ __ ] obvious
today on this episode of bottom gear
gone doesn't know
right to left connor breaks another
vehicle don't test me gone i'll do it
think about it gone if your bike breaks
you get to go in the car can i just
break my bike right now or
i threw my bike off the cliff i don't
know about you boys i was tired of
taking
l's on all the challenges and this time
i knew it was my time to shine shall we
don't talk to me
perhaps we could high five we're so
close to each other
i need to get gone well then yeah go get
gone he's probably not even on the
bridge yet
am i mad that he passed me no because
i'm like him
i actually bike road the hallway what a
view
but [ __ ] this for you and it wouldn't
just stop there
guess who can see you
oh my god this is who's that behind me
i see you too gant oh [ __ ] oh no
they already [ __ ] see me what the
[ __ ] oh
god god where'd you go i was just
starting to have some
fun damn it can't even [ __ ] here
understand conor anymore
oh sh it's oh
[ __ ]
what happened yeah
[ __ ] you god oh [ __ ] here i caught
yeah what happened uh chain
got unhinged oh [ __ ] it was done i had
broken down
my chain was stuck i didn't even know if
i could make the meeting point in time
and worst of all i would have to deal
with connor's smug
face it all looked lost but then
joey hatched a cunning plan can you come
and pick garth and i off
and drive us to the observation point
[Laughter]
this boy talking so much [ __ ]
considering he was on a ferry for half
the [ __ ] time
let's see how he [ __ ] likes it some
will say this is cheating
others will say it's it's different
you can't cheat if you're just smart the
plan was simple
we drive past conor to give gantt a
chance to fix his bike
and he'd be none the wiser the only
challenge was
making him think we were still behind
him i mean
conor was the one who was like let's
turn off the gps's
all right bro we'll play to your game to
be fair
the man was on a [ __ ] ferry for half
the time all right we're just leveling
the playing field right now i'm making
excuses i don't feel guilty at all
you want to say i'm cheating yeah i'm
[ __ ] cheating [ __ ] you connor
please slow down connor let us catch up
yeah that's what i'm doing
now [ __ ] you go ahead we'll catch up no
it's okay i'll wait for you guys
little does he know oh we're gonna catch
up all right
where are you boys the bottom of the
hill no don't worry man just go ahead
where are you at we like literally
just got onto the island well you just
came off the bridge
yeah we just came off the bridge but we
were hanging back well i was hanging
back to help gaunt with his uh
chain out of fairness for the boys i
will wait
because what's the point in winning if i
can't talk [ __ ] to them on the radio i
want them to be close enough so that i
can talk smack
connor was none the wiser he was waiting
on the bridge as we had told him to
because we were all going to get a drone
shot but of course
he was in for a big surprise there was a
big [ __ ] spider over here let me get
this gopro on so i can show you how
gargantuan this boy is
i'm gonna ask connor if he can go under
the bridge for a drone shot down okay
all right the boys want drone shots i'm
good so you're putting this helmet on
behind this bush onto your on my right
okay oh my god there it is
okay are you moving now
yes i am moving now
hey connor bye
hey connor oh are you there
i waited for god and he [ __ ] scammed
me
are you kidding me he probably still
thinks i'm at the bottom yeah
yeah yo connor i uh i just got to the
bottom of the hill so i'm coming up now
i'm on the bridge right now but uh come
on come on the bridge
fire i don't know
uh how far am i swiping on the bridge by
the way
all the way to the end [ __ ] i'll
see i'll see you on the other side
[Laughter]
uh me and joey are in the car right now
so uh you have
fun cycling i always knew you were weak
kant i knew it from birth
they had cheated the audacity
i couldn't believe it [ __ ] god man [ __ ]
god he's already giggling in the car
having a great time
yeah sure i was but [ __ ] me don't talk
about me
focus on god he's the one cheating broke
my butt yeah whatever dude like i broke
my back okay gone
come on we were cheating we fully admit
it
but considering that conor had skipped
an entire island a bit earlier
we decided to level the playing field
and
have a tiny bit of a head start so yes
we have just
magically teleported in front of conor i
don't even know
if he knows that we are still in the
race
um he will know soon enough though yeah
he will know when he sees us
magically at the observatory we passed
him and he was still like
guys there's still a drone shot going on
right guys this hap where's my drone
shot so we didn't want to fully cheat
though we're about
i'd say five kilometers we're still
going to complete the race yeah we're
about five kilometers from the end all
right
and we off boys bye i just turned right
here right
even having gone ahead we still had one
final hill to climb
and oh boy was this the final boss of
all
hills so it seems like my issue before
was that
my gears were broken so anytime i
put up the seventh gear which is the
highest gear
the chain disconnects this is so
[ __ ] it's literally been uphill
for like 30 minutes how can it do that
how do hills do that who made hills man
that's [ __ ] up they should never be
allowed to have that many consecutive
hills
oh my god dude look at this hill this is
actually one of the biggest hills
like the steepest well every hill must
go down i guess
that's true in life i'm pretty
far ahead to the point where i can just
i can just chill i can just i can just
walk this baby up
hey how's it going want an update
what's up joey engander ahead of you
know what yes
why gallant had an accident with his
bike it's a little bit broke
what's joey's excuse uh jerry's one of
the [ __ ] girl in the car
are you kidding me so they're about
10-15 minutes ahead of you so you've
still got a chance
you're [ __ ] kidding me we all know
that i won legit
but i mean they still don't know about
the whole scandal
i don't even know about that we'll talk
about that later we should have used the
car for this one hill park man
[ __ ] the rest of it that's exactly what
i was thinking man there's no way maybe
i can catch up
i'm gonna try my [ __ ] best to kill
these [ __ ] jokes
hey connor this thing's cocking me i
want to go
this better all be straight mark my
words
it's like that point where you think you
defeat the final boss but you've
realized he has three more health bars
jesus christ man this is just pain
there's no enjoyment anymore
so we have gotten to the final point
of this race of the time trial and i
would like to post a time
of 1 hour and 31 minutes now that's
that's a pretty solid time i think
but joe's got an even better time yeah
i've i have actually broken the one
minute uh one minute
one hour and 30 minute barrier with one
hour and 29 minutes 18
seconds damn dude and now all that we
have to wait
for is to see what connor's time is yeah
that's i'm curious i'm curious i'm
curious as well what do you think do you
think he's gonna you think he's gonna
come under two hours
let's hope so i don't wanna wait here
for too long i mean he's so slow
like why is he so slow jesus man hey
connor you're in range yet
yeah i am cheetah what's up oh he's in
range
how are you doing man as an honorable
man i'm happy with my choice
[Laughter]
how [ __ ] far ahead did you go jesus
christ
we just went a bit further than the
bridge man that's [ __ ] you probably
went half the [ __ ] island
you're chatting out your ass no no what
are you talking about man you're all
losers at the end of the day
anyway we've posted our times we're just
waiting for your time now what's your
excuse
joey god's chain broke what's yours joey
i'm tired
pieces of [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm tired of
waiting [ __ ] you god
if we didn't have this we it would just
be like three silent cyclists
just talking to themselves this entire
time it just be
it's just been like watching three j
vlogs
[Laughter]
all right hopefully i can get a little
bit up this hill more than i would by
walking
but he said 3.4 kilometers for [ __ ]
sake
that's ridiculous
ah look at them smug
look how smug they are he made it
well look who's not riding his bike
look who cheated gaunt i got here on my
own
do you know how that feels kant do you
know how that feels mister i took a
[ __ ] cruise across two [ __ ]
islands
yes i did and it was wonderful thank you
very much i had a nice leisurely drive
i did not have a choice in that decision
you chose to bend the rules
that was your call how do you want to
end this video do you think i think
about that right now i've been cycling i
don't know if you've done it
yeah we did actually first half first
half let me guess you skipped the like
four kilometers hill
i have no idea what you're talking about
yeah yeah you don't cause you skipped it
you would know if you went through that
pain
we went through this pain oh this is
nothing compared to what it was earlier
sounds like a u issue yeah i don't know
man those first two islands were pretty
tough not gonna lie i mean you have no
proof
that you can show us now that it was
like a hard hill yeah
so you know you can watch my video you
can see me [ __ ] dying i don't watch
trash taste videos
i just i just skip connor's parts i
don't watch it for you control left gant
in the chat
to be like who's talking about me all
right i don't give a [ __ ] about the
wow that's awful so what was your time
dude
yeah what was your time what was my time
well are we count
factoring in the cheating or no no we're
countering you what it says
what is your time one forty three three
forty three
so really you're gonna count like the
car
look at joey jayson got a sweat on him
he hasn't [ __ ] done anything
okay in the rules it's a time trial
right
it said this is the time to get to the
ending checkpoint
on your bike
this is a bike challenge navi get the
paper yeah it didn't it didn't say on
the bike it said to get to the
checkpoint it's okay
i'll take solace in the fact that i i
got a forfeit win i just not the way i
wanted to win
you know i crushed you easily you know
overtook you in five minutes when you
had four minutes ahead of me gone
that must have been humiliating even
when he thinks he's got the w just
ultimately he got the l
what do you what do you think chad what
do you think yeah what do you think
because
i will say at least we completed on the
bikes that we started with
it's not my fault if my bike broke hey
my bike broke and it's still here
it's a what your chain fell off that's
not broke gone
hey man whatever i just find the way i
persevere
physically exhausted and the point
system now far
out the window we had made it three
unfit weaves on their bikes with
a little bit of assistance and we were
rewarded with the
stunning view of the final bridge to the
final island
i'm gonna just say it even these stairs
are like yeah they hurt
they hard to go up look at that look at
these piddly little stairs
oh fantastic oh god
more stairs
so guys we made it we did indeed make it
i'm gonna throw up is that the last
bridge
that's the last bridge that is the last
period oh [ __ ] and it's also the longest
and then that is the
mainland right over there final thoughts
well i mean we still got a cycle so i'm
kind of not too excited really if i'm
honest
i think though we should do this last
stretch together yeah
like good friends if we must shall we
boys considering you've
ruined the sanctity of the sport what's
the point of competing anymore
it doesn't mean [ __ ] exactly we're all
just friends let's just get home
and i want to i want to rest onset and
beer and and cry
at the same time i'm up for i'm not for
doing this last stretch
you see this bridge it's a metaphor oh
my god
shut up god before we cross the bridge
we might just be you know normal you
know
normal anime nerds otakus whatever you
want to call us
but after we cross the bridge we will be
invigorated we would have achieved
something that's
not i'm just talking about it's like a
rage shadow legends sponsorship script
what is this [ __ ]
we had cycled to one of the most
beautiful landscapes you can find in
all of japan and there was little we
could do but marvel at its beauty
oh very nice tired battered and broken
we had one final hurdle to overcome the
kurushima kaikou bridge
not just the longest bridge on the route
but one of the longest bridges
in all of japan four kilometers of
pure bridge and yet another hill to
claim
the only solace we had was we were
suffering
as much as each other here we go
all right let's go oh my ass hurts my
ass hurts so much
can't sit down ah ah
is this what hemorrhoids feels like i
genuinely think i have aids
or hemorrhoids i feel like my legs are
just making battery acid now
ow ow ow what are we doing here
just to suffocate i want to cry
why do cyclists do this i don't know why
why do they why do they think this is
fun
people legit do this for fun people do
this off camera unironically
imagine doing this not for content i
hate my life so much right now
ah i can't guys i can't
i need a break can't [ __ ] do this
anymore
oh my arse we're waiting for you
come on you can do it
ah go take the lead
okay yeah oh
i'm gonna wait at the top okay i'll walk
with you guys
like how many more things can you break
i thought my spirit was broken
five hours ago my mind my mental
and uh soon enough my ligaments are
gonna break now i truly understand the
hentai tag
mind break we've been doing this
all day i know i could have binge an
entire anime during this time
we've been doing it basically since we
woke up morning till
night i'm not even talking
i'm just i'm just so tired i just
i just wanted to end i want the
suffering to end
the drones behind you wait really
oh yeah we see it all right whoa god god
god
my legs just gave up there for a second
take it nice and slow
slow down no need to worry no no
no no i insist i'll do it myself
going over the bumps hurts so much
ow ow ow
any bump right i think just like the
sheer willpower has just like
numbed my legs and butt yeah and i just
don't feel anything anymore
i feel like this day may have given me a
permanent fear of hills
and just slight inclines is there
another [ __ ] bridge
i think so oh my god no way
why am i here just to suffer
just a [ __ ] cry that ain't right man
it ain't right oh my god the moment my
ass lifts off
the chair is like the most excruciating
pain
just plant it in that man don't move it
where's the stop point
tell me so i can stop this last time
i'll never start again
ah [ __ ] thank you for warning me god
now i know that's there it's pretty dark
i can
barely see anything the lights they do
nothing and i'm sure the gopros can only
see my face but
it is very dark wow that got dark fast
cycling terminal to the left i see the
finish line oh
look at that look at how beautiful that
looks
whoa let's go
oh my god i'm in such pain
i've got [ __ ] arthritis for sure bro
[ __ ] yeah boys
oh [ __ ] algon you've got [ __ ] all
over your hand all right we're finally
finally [ __ ] tired game is we are
done that bridge was so long
i i am broken physically mentally
spiritually my ligaments are probably
broken as well
you know like every anime when they get
punched hard enough they they [ __ ]
cough up blood i feel like i just wanted
to
keep just cough up blood every second
i'm on the [ __ ] hill like
but i gotta keep fighting for the relief
village but
this is the cycling terminal which means
that we
trash taste boys have officially
completed the shimanami kaido trail
i i i i like attempted to muster up
some happy feelings there i was like i
mean i wouldn't be happy too if i didn't
do it all
you know i mean i'm just saying i mean
if i cheated someone went on a ferry
uh not my [ __ ] choice i had to go
you [ __ ] said well then you've missed
you you must blame the gotcha
i mean you you can't it was kind of your
fault that you had to go yeah
yeah you're the one that popped the tire
we're never gonna hear the end of this
and we'll cut back to the studio now
anyway yeah all right so we'll
we'll come to when we're not dead yeah
all right
boys i have to ask one question how does
it feel to be a cheater
a dirty little cheetah i feel good i
feel
great actually i feel [ __ ] that was the
hardest challenge
i've done in my life probably can we
please make the next one
not physically like suffering i want to
shuffle for the videos no i i really
don't
i i was like i thought it was okay
suffering as a thought but then i did it
and halfway through i wanted to end my
life
i wanted it to be over i was fine
cheating and you know what
i you know i i was going back looking
through it i think we kind of skies
called cycled around the same distance
so that that makes me feel yeah
we leveled the playing field i had no
choice you guys
you guys chose to ruin the sanctity of
our race
i couldn't believe it i actually ran the
numbers boys because i was that
determined that i went through all the
footage to check
turns out even if i didn't break for 30
minutes and you still cheated i actually
still would have beat you
on the time you were that desperate for
adults how desperate i was for a w
i was willing to assume there was any
sanctity
this is trash taste i would forget this
on the next special voice
maybe don't break a bike next time and
you can play by the rules
but uh i play fast and loose like i do
god sometimes things get broken
but uh yeah how do boys feel about
completing the challenge i mean i
i feel i feel like you know i skipped a
fair bit but i still feel happy that i
actually did it yeah it feels good being
the real winner you know that's what i
want to say
all right i've finally become keep
talking about trash
see any final thoughts on the challenge
itself i would actually really like to
do that again
without cameras and be able to do it
yeah yeah i want to do that
in more than a single day i want to
spread out over like multiple days
no it's fine come on no it's not fine
it's not it's fine
you can do that you know what i want to
do actually i want to go on the ferry
you know like we never figured out what
it was like to be on the ferry this was
the perfect time for us to have a beach
episode
and we were just suffering the entire
time i'm salty where's where's our beach
episode that's our next space that's our
next special the beach
there's no there's no challenges it's
just the beach episodes
but yes um i bet chris would come to
that one yeah definitely
yeah i want to give a quick shout out to
our patrons for allowing us to make a
challenge like this this was
as you can probably tell a very
expensive challenge to do
a lot of logistics and it was way harder
to film than the drifting episode wasn't
it
yeah well when you're spanning over 100
kilometers there's cars involved
cameraman it is a bit of a mess
literally double the cameras double the
staff like just
double everything double rip my wallet
so if you want to support these episodes
of trash taste and we have so many more
ideas that are even more crazy than this
and if you want to get in and support
that please do consider going to our
patreon and
you'll get your name in the credits like
all
these lovely people lovely patrons who
who uh watched us suffer for their money
so
thank you very much [ __ ] you but thank
you
and there are definitely more specials
and challenges to come so hopefully you
guys stick around as well
so i guess we'll see you guys soon in
the next trash taste special
bye bye
[Music]
you